you suffered from depression
war has been some of the darker places
you've gone in your in your mind
you know i needed therapy man i needed
therapy for the longest time i just
didn't get it and i uh
so because of that i
uh
i i would go through
like bouts of like
paralytic depression
like suicidal depression suicidal
ideations that were more than just
ideations i mean i think like
people get afraid when the thought of
suicide appears
in their consciousness they get really
scared of themselves so they think
there's something like
[ __ ] what's going on with me why would i
think that but i think if we are
suffering and you know as a natural part
of not of wanting to reduce suffering or
not feel bad anymore
i mean
suicide is going to be not like if we're
just you know you're just looking what
are all the options let's brainstorm
here you know what i mean i can start
drinking more water
i can start jogging get some therapy
call my friends all the stuff we all
hear or i could just
i think the height of my apartment
building is probably the definitely the
right height to kill myself and then you
and then
so where
for me like the few times where the
ideation has gone towards like
well when would i do that
how do i what you know what do i need to
like
accomplish that when then like that's
where it gets really [ __ ] scary
that's where it's like terrifying so you
start the actual
details of the planning of how to commit
suicide yeah
what's going to be the least painful way
to do it what's going to be the most
instantaneous way to do it what's the
you know and with you know with
depression because it it can be
progressive
you know this is why you have to really
just stay on top of anyone who's gone
through depression knows what i'm
talking about you gotta stay on top of
it like you might need medication you
know i know this is controversial now
but it's still better than dying if you
ask me but at some point with depression
it like becomes paralyzing so you don't
want to get out of bed anymore and
you're not taking showers anymore and
you don't want to talk to anybody
anymore and you're not answering your
phone anymore and you know
so like in a dark place that you might
be in
it still might get worse so you should
really yes do everything you can
to immediately control you and that's
the problem with that specific
psychological disorder
that's the problem because it the things
it's like if you start listening to what
you wanted you think it's you it's the
depression you start listening to it
it wants you to stay in bed
it's and then you're getting those
[ __ ] depression sleeps
you know or you wake up and you're more
tired like it's not working you're
trying to escape reality by sleeping and
and and so
yeah like you have to like
you're it's you're fighting for your
you're literally fighting for your life
it might not seem like that because you
can't if you could see depression if you
could see it if you knew you had some
inky
vaporous
octopus thing that was just wrapping
around you more and more and more and
more you would probably do everything
you could to rip that [ __ ] thing off
your body and if you couldn't get it off
your body you would
be calling people to get help so it
doesn't feel like a fight because you're
exhausted there's no reason to move
there's no you don't see the meaning for
any of it so it doesn't feel like a
battle but it is a battle you're not
feeling i mean that's the other thing
you're just you're basically not feeling
you're like you you start going numb at
least that was my experience with it
numb and tired and then
increasingly numb and tired and then
increasingly sort of disconnecting from
reality and then somewhere in there
that's when you start playing around
with the idea
of like i don't know if it's worth it i
don't know now you know i think compared
to
some of my friends who haven't survived
obviously who haven't survived
depression like mine was definitely
not whatever theirs was like i've heard
uh
i mean to understand it for folks out
there maybe you haven't gone through it
just imagine
if like how bad you have to feel if
death is the salute like like violence
against yourself so that you die is the
solution like just
it flies in the face of everything
so i i would yeah that was definitely
the darkest place
is it just that death doesn't seem like
because you don't care about anything
anymore that death just doesn't seem
like that bad yeah
um
like you're not able to appropriately
assign
the negative cost to this the solution
right just seems like a reasonable
solution yeah and but in in in and but i
think also what's going along with it is
like
it's not like your your brain isn't
working like you're you're not thinking
you're obviously you're not thinking
clearly like
at least again this is was my experience
of it
it's a fog you're in some kind of
like you're confused there's confusion
there's
shame you feel embarrassed you feel
embarrassed you want to get out of bed
you want to do stuff you want to be
compelled to be social and do all this
stuff but you're not you're not and like
you seem if people don't know what's
going on and you're not telling them
because you're embarrassed because you
you want like you want to have some like
you know
uncorrupted
un
warped psyche
you know you're like it invites you to
be secret about it that's one of its
first tricks is it tells you not to tell
anybody and and that's deadly within in
that case is deadly what was the source
of light what was the
what were for you
and in general the ways out
yeah
so for me i've had their their the
solutions and again man for my depressed
friends out there please don't get mad
at me i'm not doing the thing i'm like
just put on a smile or any of that
[ __ ] because it doesn't feel like
that when when you when you're like in
the and when you're fighting it it's
it's like you are
you're in a uh
i don't know why i'm keep i keep using
these stupid gravity analogies but it's
like the gravity's been turned up on
your planet in every single way by so
getting out of bed you know like
by the way gravity and quantum mechanics
one of the most beautiful things about
our reality what the hell is each of
those things right so right this isn't
you're not just talking about happy
language it's still
physicists pretend they understand
something we're still at the very
beginning understanding this mysterious
world of ours that seems to be
functioning according to these
weirdly simple
and yet universally powerful laws
which we don't fully yet understand so
um please the metaphor and the analogy
of gravity okay thank you fully
applicable i don't know any other way to
put it then it's like somebody turned
the gravitational field of your mattress
up so everything is heavy heavy your
body's heavy you don't want to get out
of bed you will consider [ __ ] or
pissing the bad because you're just like
who gives a [ __ ] i'll just lay in my
[ __ ] and piss you're dying you're like
you're you're you're it it's none of it
makes sense so
um
and i feel like in retrospect i'm making
what i what i've done a little like i
had more lucidity it was more of like a
when you're
uh right you know you're wrestling with
someone and you're just like
well you do
yeah it's different for you but for me
if i'm wrestling i'm not thinking about
jiu jitsu moves i'm like survival
so it's like that it is a struggle
like it's like uh you really
have to deliberately yeah fight
everything so
you
start so you can almost have a
conversation with the depression
and then what you do is you start doing
the opposite
of everything it's telling you to do so
it's telling you
lay in bed
so you get out of bed
it's definitely telling you don't
[ __ ] exercise you're gonna go [ __ ]
exercise that's not gonna do anything
you can't you probably have a heart
attack you really want to go outside
don't
go [ __ ] exercise and it'll feel
crazy and you won't want to do it if you
wanted to do it you wouldn't be
depressed like how often do you hear
like one of the symptoms of depression
you want a jog you want to get on a bike
you know you don't hear that that's not
a symptom so you start
at least i i one one solution i
started doing the opposite of whatever
the voice is telling you do the opposite
that and then
suddenly that the the gravitational
field
diminishes a little bit it doesn't go
all the way away and that's where you
can fall right back into it because you
just feel even slightly better you're
like oh okay i fixed it
you know really i think if you like in
having been through therapy
the the
best solution would be
go to a [ __ ] therapist
as quickly as you can
just sit down with him and tell him
what's going on
i know what you're thinking how am i
going to find a therapist just
do it google it go on yelp all this [ __ ]
feels
impossible you're like i don't want to
turn on the computer i don't do any of
this you just have to you have to you do
it if you're on fire you do it if you're
on fire and someone's like you know
here's a way to not be on fire just this
particular fire is
it doesn't make you want to run around
screaming it just makes you want to fall
asleep forever and that but those
little steps
i got lucky because it worked it worked
i started exercising i'd been on
antidepressants before
uh when i was originally diagnosed with
it and
help or not you know i even with all the
current research coming out about
that maybe we were all wrong about our
understanding of depression i do feel
like
it helped in a certain way like it
definitely
it definitely like made me stop thinking
about it stop the intrusive thoughts and
but i don't know how much of that was
placebo or how much of that i don't know
but then also like i couldn't come
anymore that was the other [ __ ] up
thing like you're you can't have orgasms
and um
which might not sound like a big deal
but
um
you know when i told my therapist that
they actually took me off him because i
think she was realizing
that it started diminishing a little bit
but
the one i'm talking about now that
whatever episode or whatever you want to
call it i just got lucky because it
worked it worked and i started feeling
better thank god now
if you suffer from depression out there
and you've had a remission of the
depression you know it's it's really
like it's scary to have mental illness
because
um
everyone gets bummed out i mean that's
just normal like you're going to get
bummed out no i want to do anything
sometimes it doesn't mean you have a
clinical depression you might just be
bummed out or grieving you might be any
number of things but when
i when i get really nervous
if some of those symptoms start showing
up and
um
at one point i felt like that was
happening again
and i did
intramuscular ketamine therapy
which
now that was the damnedest thing i've
ever experienced aside from the fact
that ketamine is
immensely psychedelic
the
i i just remember going back to the
hotel after the experience
with a clinician and um
like you know it's like
with depression it's like a headache
that starts coming on but you're like
this headache might last for years it
might last for six months it might get
worse and worse and worse and so
i went back to the hotel room
and it was just
gone like i just felt normal i felt i
felt great it was like
the most remarkable thing ever so
you know look at the research on
ketamine right now it's like it's it's
not like [ __ ] it's not like woo
science there's really really good data
out there showing that something like
i think it's 60
i don't know what the percentage is but
60 of people with
uh depress an endogenous depression when
they
get ketamine therapy will experience
remission regardless of whether you trip
out or not it just you know does
something that i don't know if they know
what it is yet i don't care if they do
but that one thing worked and basically
you keep fighting until something works
exactly it's a survival issue and it's a
survival issue it's just i think because
it's kind of so slow moving you might
even forget it's progressive you or you
know you could easily just think that
you're just a kind of bummed out person
or you start thinking that these aspects
of your
psychology are permanent when they don't
have to be
what about other people in your life
what advice would you give to people
that have loved ones who suffer from
depression
what are they to do
okay now this is really like
man it's really dark
here's
number one
this is what somebody told me when i
lost a friend of suicide you know
because when you lose a friend to
suicide when you lose a loved one to
suicide
you're going to blame yourself it's a
ever like in the in the cir
periphery of suicide there is a
circumference of guilty people who all
feel like oh if only i'd said this at
the right time if only i'd listened more
if only i'd seen that warning sign or if
only this or that
um
it's interesting in that
with other
forms of like disease
you know
if if your loved one
dies from cancer say more than likely
you're not going to be thinking like oh
i should have cured their cancer you
know like you're it's a tragedy but at
least you're not like uh if only i had
you still might think that's part of
grief but
um
it's not a sticky in many of the other
situations here the guilt can really
stay for a long time yep
so
you
number one
it's we're talking about a pro
progressive disease that can lead to
death and if somebody commits suicide
they wanted to commit suicide and at
least what i've been told is you're you
can't stop it this is gonna happen
it's gonna happen there are no magic
words there's nothing you could do
so you know people who've lost people to
suicide you know what i'm talking about
like you know you you you can watch it
happen in real time and there's there's
nothing you could do
um
that being said
you know being responsive to when it
seems like someone's really reaching out
for help and knowing that maybe
even it though it might if especially if
it's someone who's like doesn't talk
like this a lot of the time and
sentences start coming out of their
mouth that if you weren't really paying
attention
might not seem like a big deal but for
this person it's kind of a novelist that
all of a sudden
that's happening
now there
that's when you can be a good listener
and you know open up to them and hear
what they're saying and
see like oh [ __ ] are they asking me for
is this them asking for help and even if
you're like i'm i don't know what to do
you know
uh at least you can like
start checking in on them
you know start like
help them understand that you're there
for them and then hopefully get them
into therapy get them to a doctor get
them to a professional who can like
see what's going on there so that and
then there's hope and even then there
might not be hope actually you know
doctors can't stop it there's no
sometimes it just that's the way it goes
but
you know i know that like um
being sensitive
if somebody's like all of a sudden
hitting you up or reaching out to you
that normally isn't like that
and just what's going on how are you and
just listen which in general
depression or not is probably a good
thing to do
yeah to to to to to truly listen
it's like are you okay yeah yeah
because people have you know i don't
this whole thing of like cries for help
man they don't sometimes they just look
like a weird text
you know something you don't realize for
the person to send that [ __ ] text
they've been thinking about it all
morning they've been just trying to get
their [ __ ] get their phone up
from the floor
so you know
i think that that's it i mean i get what
i don't know i don't know i've had
friends like
kill themselves so
and uh
many of them it wasn't like
sadly it was like i don't know i don't
know what could have been done but
but there's still
still a guilt in the back of your head
for the rest of my life for sure always
will be
yeah i mean yeah but again what are you
gonna do you but even that it's a part
of love
that's right that's right
yeah that's right you could yeah you
know we feel guilt gree part of grief is
guilt you know i like you we always
could have been better people
we always could have been better people
you getting a victor franco much yeah of
course
man search for meaning
the invitation to
live
your life as though you'd been on your
deathbed
and have been given the chance to go
back and not make the same mistakes
i i returned to that idea all the time
meaning it's like okay whatever you did
before
this moment
was too late
but now
you know this is where you can start
this is where you can start and
yeah so
i i think that's for a neurotic like me
that's super important because otherwise
i'll just get like too lost in the weeds
of [ __ ] shitty things i did in the past
you